if you were in a picture oh yeah we know
that we we see that person we're gonna
go ahead and you're arrested we're
closing your bank account down we're
doing this doing that locking you up
whatever whatever they did to them I
have no idea I wasn't there but I will
say this as an influencer online
was I asked by followers hey are you
going to go I didn't think it was going
to go that way I thought it was going to
go like a totally different way where
like we were going to get hurt because
people didn't like Trump supporters so I
was like I'm good on this one I would
recommend you guys don't go right
because maybe we'll get hurt but they
could go after all the little guys like
myself at the time that might have been
like go there let's go there let's let's
it's just crazy I think it's going to be
bigger personalities because as we move
into 2024 their goal is to silence
anyone who would provide public support
for Trump yeah so first they go for his
legal team anybody who helped him